you know what warner brothers i'm
starting to think that at this point
that you and i
are destined to do this
forever
[Music]
i don't think i actually appreciate how
outdated a reference that is don't care
moving on so
warner brothers
warner discovery whatever the hell
they're calling themselves now post
merger
um okay so originally
this video was just going to be about
the very sudden cancellation of the
batgirl movie which was finished
it was finished and now suddenly it's
not coming out
however
that turned out to be
step one in just a rolling snowball of
nonsense that has gone on so uh i've got
a bit to go over and there's a number of
reasons i want to do this one i want to
try and give people something close to
as comprehensive a look as somebody who
does not have uh inside sources into any
of this can give two i wanted to spell
some of the stuff that i see people
still
throwing out there one of the things
that's tough about a story like this is
there was a lot of stuff thrown out
immediately in the wake of uh bat girl's
cancellation i almost had bat woman uh
that was a tv show that was also
canceled uh but not related batgirl's
cancellation there were a bunch of
rumors thrown out and a couple of them
turned out to be true and then i see
people assuming that all the other
rumors thrown out at the same time were
also true and some of them have turned
out not to be at least not right now so
there's a lot to get through there's a
lot of parts and as always i want to try
and explain so best as i can understand
what the thought process and the
mentality is because i see a lot of
people asking flat out what on earth are
they thinking why are they doing this
and i do think i can offer some insight
into that now i'm not going to say
whether or not i think these are good
ideas
i might say that but i'm going to save
that towards the end but i am going to
be trying to explain what the thought
process and mentality would be behind
some of these moves so
let's start with the cancellation of
batgirl because that's what kicked
everything off except it didn't not by
itself
it was done in conjunction with another
cancellation of another film that just
didn't get nearly as much press because
it was a smaller budget film that was
nowhere near as anticipated not only did
the plug get pulled on batgirl which was
a 90 million dollar film
that was going to be released directly
to hbo max but it also
saw the cancellation of scoob a haunted
holiday which is the sequel to i forget
what gary came out but the animated
scoob uh movie and that was a 40 million
dollar they're both just getting
scrapped and in both cases they were
pretty much done and in fact in the case
of scoob weird little side tangent
they actually recently recorded the
soundtrack for it
after it was already cancelled
the uh the conductor uh or the composer
maybe it's the same guy i'm not sure but
he basically said we were already paid
for it i guess we might as well record
it because like the money had been spent
for them to do the recording it's just
the project was cancelled so
weirdness and that that kind of
emphasizes how last minute out of
nowhere just harsh pulling of the plug
this was as far as the people involved
in the actual makings of these movies
went this is not something that was uh
oh writing's on the wall they're gonna
put they had no reason to think any of
this was gonna happen it was pretty dang
sudden
now
official word on this is a couple of
things if you well depending on where on
the internet especially here on youtube
you go you will see a lot of claims of
batgirl was super woke and it tested
badly because of that and that's why
they pulled it now
how woke
like which is a meaningless freaking
term at this point but how woke the
movie was or wasn't we don't know we'll
never freaking see it now but they base
that solely off the fact of the casting
of a non-white uh actor to play batgirl
because that alone is enough to set a
lot of the rage merchants off the
testing not well there's some truth to
that but specifics are hard to come by
and depending on what source you go
it's not across the board there were
some reports saying that it was testing
quite badly there were others that were
testing decently or that the acting was
good but the story needed some work like
probably needed uh maybe some reshoots a
little bit of re-editing not completely
out of the realm of something that is
standard and even when a movie tests
badly
when it is this expensive it generally
doesn't get shelved the standard
practice for when a studio has a movie
that they don't think they're going to
make their money back on actually
releasing it is to sell it
sell it to somebody else like sell it
you know 50 cents on the dollar in terms
of your budget to somebody else who
thinks it will make that money back
you just do that
well these days with streaming you have
the alternate
option which is what the movie was
originally designed to do which is just
release it on streaming you remove the
need for any kind of rollout for the
actual wide release
so you lose that expense and it will
severely cut down the marketing expense
because let's be honest a lot of the
stuff that gets released directly to
streaming does not get marketed nearly
as heavily a lot of it doesn't get
marketed in television or print runs or
even online it's like a couple of
trailers
drop of some ads on youtube like but
leave it at that it's a significantly
lower
expense in terms of marketing it or at
least you have the option to go lighter
on the marketing costs
but
they're just shelving it
it and scoob completely now i talked
about the test screenings and this other
stuff the official word from david
zaslov who is now the ceo of warner
brothers discovery he's basically
pointing to an overall change in
strategy that there was part of the
outgoing uh heads of warner brothers
strategy that he just didn't think it
was a good idea and primarily revolves
around two things the idea of mid-budget
films really at all or the idea of
making films for streaming
as well as the more child-targeted uh
stuff he didn't think there was much
value in either of those and with
batgirl and scoob fitting into that mid
budget made for streaming and children
focus respectively
he just
he's claiming that he's scrapping them
because that that's not what they want
to do now he wants them to focus
specifically when it comes to films on
big budget blockbuster tentpoles he
wants to be in the blockbuster making
business none of this mid-tier stuff
now if you've been following warner
brothers for a while
this is not a new strategy this is not a
new shift
about
out of guess about seven years ago i'm
not gonna go back and find out exactly
when it was but it was about seven years
ago that warner brothers said we're not
gonna do mid-budget movies anymore and
we're not going to do non-franchise
movies anymore we are in the business of
making
dc superhero movies harry potter movies
and lego movies so uh spoiler alert on
how that worked out for them
the dc movies just started to fall apart
for them pretty much as soon as suicide
squad was released to massively tempered
reviews and then batman v superman
really failed to perform what they
wanted i know it made a lot of money but
it was supposed to make a lot more than
it did and then it's been an absolute
crap shoot for them ever since
harry potter was going okay right up
until jk rowling um opened her mouth and
has now continually been damaging the
brand and has made it controversial by
association and as for the lego movies
even though they were all pretty decent
the actual returns they got on them were
diminishing so much from film over film
over film
that they actually let the rights to
that lapse warner brothers isn't even
doing lego stuff anymore
so the last time they decided to go all
in on big budget it didn't work for them
and it wasn't that long ago
so i feel like the people who have been
ousted in terms of making these major
decisions who had decided to diversify a
little bit more probably remembered when
going all in didn't work for them but
now we've got a new guy in
who says they should go all in again
and it's one of those things that like
yeah if these things hit that's a good
strategy but that's a big if and it's an
if that warner brothers has whiffed on
already but coming back to batgirl and
scoob there's actually probably another
reason why they were scrapped instead of
just putting them on because like i said
they're done like even if they're crap
people were still interested in seeing
them in terms of scoob that's a
kid-centric movie it was going to be out
in time for halloween that was going to
probably get going to get decent numbers
and even if it was for train wreck
reasons batgirl probably would have
gotten decent viewing numbers as well
but
if they don't release them at all
they get a write down on their taxes
because they get to write it off as a
loss
and if if it's the one-two combination
of well these things don't fit our
current strategy anyway and they think
they will make equivalent or near-to-it
amounts of money just in the tax
write-off as they would actually
releasing the thing
then yeah from a business strategy that
does make sense it's incredibly callous
to
the work of the people who made these
of the artists of anyone who ever cared
how dare you care this is just an asset
we're not going to make as much money as
we want off it so nobody gets it
it's what happens when
artistic works whether you think they're
good art or not but when artistic works
are treated solely as ip and properties
and assets
this is what happens
and it is again
one of the things that and like i hate
doing this i hate praising disney at all
but i will continue to say that when it
comes to ip management disney is
better about letting the art at least
vaguely resemble art even as they milk
it for way more than it's worth and we
have way too many star wars things and
we're getting to the point where even
for me who loves the marvel stuff for
getting too much marvel stuff but at the
same time they are still treating it
like there are stories to be told as
opposed to
you know
what what's what do the accountants say
which is how
warner brothers discovery appears to be
treating it which is how att treated it
before so anyone who thought that this
merger was going to be an improvement
over at t handling things so far at
least
no
no it's really not
and i think honestly the the most
surprising thing is
how much this just has not been run or
consulted by the other departments
because there's word that the head of dc
films walter hamada almost quit over
this because he was not consulted warned
nothing
they didn't even get a chance to tell
the people involved in the making this
movie that was canceled before the story
broke in the press
so
he was ticked
word now is that he is going to stay on
at least through the release of black
adam maybe more after that but at the
very least he's going to stand to them
but
it shows again a disregard
for
not only the art but these other
departments
basically saying well we're at the top
we're going to make the decision suck it
up we don't have to consult you which
like
technically they don't but that's not
how you foster a good work environment
and one of the other weird things that
they did and this one much less reported
was they have apparently started
removing movies that were made for the
streaming services
the there's at least six that came off
possibly more but uh things like
american pickle super intelligence
the witches remake with anne hathaway
those are all just gone off the surface
and again
no warning no heads up given no watch it
before it's gone just removed
quietly it basically got caught by
redditors who started compiling hey
what's missing and it's and it was all
stuff that was made specifically for the
platform which again in terms of an
overall strategy does fit with this
we're not gonna make we're not gonna
make movies just for the streaming
platform anymore which
is still weird though because
these were already on there
the money had already this isn't like
you're going well we're not gonna do
that anymore okay but you don't have to
erase the fact that you used to it
almost seemed spiteful in a way like i
think that was a bad idea so let's
pretend that it had never been made even
though i wasn't even in charge of the
company at the time that decision was
originally made which is again also kind
of a factor possibly in the um canceling
of these movies as well because it's
actually pretty standard practice that
when a new regime comes in anything that
the old regime had
greenlit
they will try and pull the plug on
unless they are pretty sure it's going
to be a very big success because if it's
a failure even though it was okayed
under the previous regime if it posts
its loss or its bad reviews while they
are in charge they will still get
assigned the blame so
that is a pretty standard thing to go
through okay what's in the works no
scrap that scrap that scrap that i'm not
taking the hit for that if those don't
work but again it's weird when it was
something that was already finished
most of the money that was going to be
spent was already spent
and so at this point it does seem a
little bit more well at best callous at
worst spiteful and then of course we
have the announcement of the
consolidation of discovery plus
and hbo max now this is something that
we don't know a ton about yet and we
don't even know what the name of this is
going to be though it is supposed to
launch start launching in various
territories summer of next year so it's
not that far away
so this was another thing that this is
one of the things that was rumored that
did end up happening getting confirmed
on a
sales call that david zaslov had with
investors now
some of the other things that were
rumored don't look like they're panning
out like there was rumor they're gonna
scrap all the scripted content they're
gonna gut hbo max they're gonna make the
whole thing much more like discovery
plus they're gonna lay off like 70 of
the people at hbo max
none of that really seems to be in the
cards at least not to that degree so
here's the thing
none of that really made so actually
ahead of time i didn't think they were
actually going to consolidate these two
services at all
it just struck me as a really bad idea
and this is where i'll editorialize a
little bit on whether or not i think any
of this is a good idea i think that's a
terrible idea they fundamentally cater
to different audiences and not to
mention the fact that hbo max is
three times as successful in terms of
number of subscribers as discovery plus
is now that doesn't make discovery plus
a failure discovery plus largely deals
with unscripted stuff that is far less
expensive to produce so it's okay that
it has fewer subscribers consolidating
it into one place
makes sense in one way but doesn't make
sense in another so it makes sense in
terms of maintaining the actual cost of
the thing
so even without you know scrapping a
whole bunch of scripted stuff which
david zaslov has said he's not going to
do
with the exception of the made for
streaming movies and also de-emphasizing
children's content which
does kind of make sense because i mean
like if you have kids were they watching
hbo max or were they watching disney
plus
there's only so much stuff on hbo max
it's really truly kid-centric despite
how much of a back catalog
hbo max has of children's stuff i don't
imagine that was the most viewed stuff
on that platform
hey folks i'm jumping in here a little
bit uh from the future and i just wanted
to say that i want to add a little bit
more in terms of the children's media
and the animated stuff i think i came
across as a little dismissive i didn't
mean to be i think i was trying to bring
about across that
david zaslov and warner brothers overall
was was being dismissive about the
children's media and the animated stuff
but i think he came across like i was
because honestly right now a lot of
animation fans are kind of worried
warner brothers owns cartoon network and
the entire backlog that that means not
just a couple of random things now
this is kind of tricky to know what
they're going to do because on the one
hand the main focus of what zaslov has
been saying and indicating has largely
been focused on the streaming platform
and it is possible that the de-emphasis
of
animated in children's media is meant
specifically for whatever the new
streaming platform is going to be so
that would put uh in the crosshairs
anything that is made for the streaming
platform not necessarily things that are
made for other networks that warner
brothers own that you know end up on the
streaming platform later that said
there's still reason to be concerned
because some of the other networks like
tbs and tnt are having
it looks like all of their original
scripted material canceled and they're
just going to be homes to
reruns and unscripted stuff so
they aren't
not doing things to uh the networks as
well it's hard to know and i do feel bad
for anybody who cares about animation
and or and or is a fan of cartoon
network and it's output now if you're
wondering why i'm actually sitting down
in front of the camera to shoot this and
i didn't just do a little voice over
jump in that's because you're gonna see
me again later on because
yeah there's there's other stuff
see in a little bit
the whole thing makes sense in terms of
consolidating your costs because the
cost of running just running the
streaming platform
in terms of the servers to run it in
terms of having to maintain the
architecture and the digital
infrastructure to run
two different streaming services that is
a higher expense
than consolidating it and putting into
one you can streamline it you can cut
your cost so from that perspective it
does make sense from most other
perspectives it it doesn't
make a lot of sense to me not to mention
the fact that i don't think they've
really considered the fact that a
if this news if this new service
launches and just
is awkward or isn't great to use or
feels like a downgrade from the other
especially from hbo max some people will
jump ship
if it comes with a price increase some
people will do that anyway and there's
going to be some people who were
subscribed to both so if they are you
know back there thinking okay so we'll
just consolidate both of these we've got
70 million some people on hbo mac 20
some odd million on uh discovery plus
you know we'll
we'll mix those together and we'll
consolidate both it'll be around 100
million right off the bat well no
some people will already be subscribed
to both so instead of getting two
subscriptions from them now you've only
got one how many people is that i have
absolutely no idea but this uh overall
notion of oh well we'll just combine
these two things and there will be no
loss it's just adding them together like
no
no that's that's
that's not how that works and as i said
as far as the cutting 70 percent of hbo
max gutting it i i never thought they
were going well i didn't think they were
going to consolidate them at all so it
shows what i know but i i'm that's been
largely debunked at this point because
they do seem to recognize that the
higher level of interest is with the
scripted stuff on hbo max so they don't
appear to be gutting all of it in fact
james gunn came out and said very
plainly don't worry about the peacemaker
series about there being another season
that show is safe so people are
definitely worried about the other stuff
getting cut but as i said so far it's
been pretty consistent
children's targeted and films made for
the streaming platform now in regards to
the fact that some films have just been
taken off as i mentioned before it's
worth noting at this point this is
something that a lot of uh advocates for
actual ownership of property by
consumers have been saying
would happen
the fact that
these platforms can just make something
go away
something you like something you would
have liked to have kept watching or
watched again might even be one of your
favorite things
increasingly few of these things are
even being released to physical media at
all
and if it's not released to physical
media
they can take it away
at any moment
you don't have ownership of it now it's
a little bit different because this is a
subscription service and you're not like
it's not like buying it digitally on on
amazon or whatever but that kind of
stuff has already happened too
there is an erosion of the very concept
of you pay money and you get to keep a
thing
this is actually very much across the
board with businesses especially
digitally based businesses they don't
want the consumer to own
anything they want us to rent
they want us to pay them a regular fee
for the privilege of getting whatever it
is they feel like getting us they no
longer want a situation where we give
them money and we get to keep a thing
this is true of streaming this is true
of video games this is true of so much
digital software like
i don't know what i'm gonna do if i ever
feel that i need to upgrade my editing
software again because nearly every
single editing platform at this point
has moved from you pay us
anywhere from i don't know 60 to 200
to get the software package and then you
just have it too you pay us a monthly
subscription for as long as you continue
to use it
and
that is that for someone who does
editing as part of their living
that's going to add up to a hell of a
lot more money
than what it would have cost me just to
buy the thing out right but i'm not
given that choice anymore this is
ultimately a goal especially with
digital goods
they don't want us to own anything so
that was a little bit of a tangential
rant couple more things to cover here
zaslov is saying that they have a
10-year plan for the dc properties which
sounds good except they had a pretty
extensive plan before for the dc
properties and it didn't work out well
but relevant to that he named certain
specific movies that he said we are
standing by because part of what he said
with batgirl is we are not going to
release a product we don't believe in
which was kind of him throwing shade and
implying that it wasn't very good but he
did specifically say you know you are
absolutely going to see the release of
black adam the next shazam movie and the
flash hold on to that one i will come
back to it
he didn't say anything either way about
aquaman 2
or the blue beetle film which has
already shot i believe now whether that
was an unintentional omission just
because he wanted to put the focus on
the stuff that is releasing uh up next
and the soonest or whether that was a
deliberate omission because those are on
the bubble we don't really know now we
got to come back to the flash because
one of the big things that people have
been going on about is oh sure you
cancelled batgirl but you're gonna
release the flash with ezra miller for
all the stuff that they're getting up to
which
yeah okay so we have to deal with that
david zaslov did say you know very
specifically we believe in the flash and
we're going to be releasing it uh he
said that prior to the latest thing
where ezra miller has now been charged
with felony burglary on top of
everything else they've been getting up
to
but uh
even with that in mind it's obviously a
very
easy thing to call
zaslav and warner brothers discovery out
on you are going to release a movie with
a star that is causing this much
continual problem but you're going to
shelve a movie that didn't have any kind
of pr issue whatsoever just because it
doesn't fit your current business
portfolio and basically yeah
yeah that's pretty much exactly it in
terms of the strategy that zasaliff has
laid out
the
big uh budget
theatrical release of flash
fits with what he says he wants the
company to be doing batgirl did not does
that make it a good decision no not
really but it does make it a fairly
consistent one
hey it's me again told you you'd see me
again uh so
a little bit of stuff has gone on in
regards to the flash and
this always i hate when this happens
there's been breaking news and it's not
fully confirmed insofar as it is like
leaked news about what is supposedly
going on now it's come from relatively
reliable sources but right now this is
unofficial um and there's also again
some wild rumors going around so i need
to try and quash that as well but
right now it looks like warner brothers
is in a bit of a crisis around flash i
think they were doing what i said they
were going to do they were just going to
wait this out that's what they were
gonna try and do but the thing is it's
not getting quieter and i think they've
realized that they can't count on miller
to not get in more trouble between now
and the release of the film next year
because as i said since zaslav's uh last
statements
miller has been charged with burglary so
you know they're still causing a lot of
problems and even the earlier stuff is
still ongoing
that having been said miller does not
appear to actually have been located
appears to be currently living with
their mother um as best as i could find
i still couldn't find if they actually
ever got served with like the protective
orders uh in regards to
toccata
gibson iron eyes although they have uh
spoken via text to business insider but
i couldn't find out if they are still in
miller's presence i don't think so the
general indication i'm getting is they
are not uh like in the same physical
space anymore but again like trying to
nail this stuff down is a real pain in
the butt but that's kind of the thing
miller is such a wild card right now
that the word that we have is that
warner brothers is considering one of
three possible actions
and these are considerations that would
make sense one and this is probably
their ideal scenario one is that miller
does like a whole big apology tour like
sits down for an interview a formal
thing and explains what the hell's been
going on with them for the last few
years and then you know says i'm sorry
i'm getting help goes into treatment for
whatever is the most relevant treatment
um
for for getting them sorted out because
i don't know what's wrong with them um
and not neither does anybody else right
now
that having been said that
they probably shouldn't count on that
like if it happens warner brothers is
gonna breathe very very easy but
uh it doesn't really seem like it's
something they should be counting on
right now and even if it happens there
isn't a ton of guarantee they're not
gonna get more trouble after that
second option which is what i think they
were probably inclined to do
prior to uh considering other ones is
that they move forward with the release
and basically completely cut ezra miller
out of the promotion do not put them out
to press junkets don't have them you
know meet with with critics or
interviewers or or promote the thing in
any way and also drop them and never use
them for the flash in any future movie
i was kind of assuming that was likely
what they were going to do anyway
so that to me kind of affirms that what
i've assumed they were already planning
is one of the things that they are
considering the final option and this is
the one i do believe honestly is the
least likely
barring like
so here's the thing
what miller has been accused of
so far none of it's good let's be very
clear but like when it came to
accusations of grooming and things of
that nature they aren't criminal
accusations it was in relation to a
protective order basically a restraining
order now if they actually get charged
criminally
with grooming activity or um anything
with a minor that could be bad enough or
if like they they i don't know
if they kill somebody like that would
definitely be bad enough but the thing
is each individual thing that they've
done or like has circled around them is
stuff that
well hollywood has a history of ignoring
you know
the the burglary
the
weird
assaults the all this stuff hollywood
has a history of ignoring it now it's
pretty atypical for it to happen
repeatedly in such a short time span of
the single person but each one of these
individual things is something that
hollywood
habitually overlooks so
unless they they really ramp it up i
would be shocked if they do in fact end
up shoving this movie i'm not shocked
that they are at least putting it in the
conversation because like i said they
probably wanted this to go away they
probably did not even consider the fact
that canceling batgirl was gonna make
people
really ramp up and renew the calls to
also cancel the flash movie for some
reason they didn't think people would
make that connection between those two
but now it has and
if there's one thing corporations hate
it's losing control of the narrative and
they don't have control of this
narrative right now
so which of these three do i think will
happen honestly i still think the second
one i still think that is most likely um
i would be shocked if miller actually
settles down enough to go into treatment
make an apology video whatever uh
considering that they haven't for
anything they've done up to this point
and this has been going on for a while
and uh the actual shelving of it again
for how expensive it is how much
probably hinges on it narratively for
what the future plans of the supposed
10-year plan are i'd be really surprised
if they shelve it
but they do appear to be at least
considering it now i did say there are
some wild rumors out there i saw things
floating around like claims that david
zaslov didn't even want to consider
shelving it but he was overruled by the
board of directors who insist that we
have this is a plan that like they're
actively talking to ezra miller and like
trying to force them to make this
apology video or all this other stuff
none of that's verified i could not
source any of that and where when i
tried to track it back it was like
twitter accounts with 2000 followers so
while i'm not going to say any of that
is definitively not true i have nothing
that i actually trust for it the three
options that they're considering i could
find relatively reliable sources on that
okay yeah
back to whatever old me said to wrap
this out
one other like weird side note that i
just i found while digging around for
stuff on this
uh apparently warner brothers discovery
has
refused the official licensing of clips
from the snyder cut um i forget what
company was but some company was like
putting something together and they just
tried to license some clips that they
were going to use in the thing and uh
they refused
because that's not the official justice
league movie
so
hate to break it to anyone who was
hoping for the restore of the snyder
verse
they really do not seem to be interested
in doing that which
again given that the snyder cut was
basically something that was it was
effectively a movie made for the
streaming platform and they're saying
they don't want to do that anymore
again it's not surprising and it's not
inconsistent with everything else
they've said if they're trying to now
distance themselves from that so what's
been the fallout from all this well the
stocks took a dip
after that earnings call
that is an indicator of something but
it's not always immediately clear what
it might be an indicator that the
investors flat out think this is a bad
idea or it might just be an indicator
that they think that the general public
will think it's a bad idea because
something can on paper appear like a
decent business decision but if you're
dependent on hooking in the public and
the consumers to buy into whatever it is
you're selling if the investors even if
they think the business plan makes sense
if they think the public won't buy into
it they'll bail anyways so
whether it is they just think it's a bad
idea or whether it's they think the
public won't go for this new
consolidated service because like hbo it
we had hbo go we had hbo now we had hbo
max and it's like they're rebooting this
service more often than they reboot the
dc universe in the comics
it's actually gotten a little bit
ridiculous when you stop and thinking
think about it and it makes it hard to
get invested in what the service has to
offer when you're going is this even
going to be around in three years
it's hard to have confidence in a
product
that doesn't stick around again to make
a comparison to video games it's like
when a video game is released and like
we will support this online experience
for 10 years guess what it's scrapped in
two
either because people weren't that into
it you released it in a buggy state
there wasn't that much content or if
you're the destiny franchise you decided
you know what
maybe we will just make a flat out
sequel so like increasingly consumers
are learning we can't trust
these companies to give us what they say
they're going to give us or to continue
to provide it even if they give it to us
initially
i think consumer confidence
is probably a big concern for a lot of
these investors
because we shouldn't be confident
they're going to keep restructuring
rearranging taking away stuff because
they can as far as they're concerned
it's their property they own it they can
do what they want with it and from a
strictly legal perspective yes that's
true
but again
it's art
art is
meant to be accessible it's meant to be
consumed and taken in and experienced
but
this is an art to them so i think that
just about covers everything i don't
think this is a particularly good idea i
get the logic behind it but i don't
think this is overall a particularly
good idea i think ultimately it will
probably not be too bad for them i think
whatever the new consolidated service is
it'll launch it'll probably underperform
for what they initially want but it'll
pick up steam later um or it'll just be
uh flat for a little bit just because
people will stick
with it because they were already
discovery plus or hbo max it's just a
question of how much better or worse the
service is and whether or not they stick
around but i don't think this is going
to be the big boost they think it is i
think it's going to be gradual at most
simply because
well
people don't have a choice
see like for me personally i'm actually
a really bad person to go by you know oh
should i keep hbo max what what's vera
gonna do well i'm gonna keep it because
there's too much stuff on there that's
related to stuff that i talk about on
here for my living so i kind of have to
but
it's it's not something i'm sure i'd be
keeping
if i didn't have this job
i mean to give it some credit
my kid was able to see steven universe
on it
she really loved that i feel like
ultimately that might be the biggest uh
positive takeaway oh i got to see the
watchmen show on there there we go
i got one really excellent thing she got
one thing she really really loved and
the rest of it's been like
well it's my job so i guess i'll keep
watching this stuff
i don't know
i i'm kind of
i'm kind of getting bombarded just by
too much stuff in general but that's
that's a whole other conversation
warner brothers discovery all of this
nonsense the cancellation bath girl the
consolidation of these projects the
possible future 10-year plan question
mark for uh the dc movies any of this
all of this what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
is what enables me to do this as my
living as i said it is because youtube
does not pay well
directly patreon is what actually keeps
my head above water at all so any amount
you're able to help is of great
assistance even if you can't do that
like share subscribe also help and even
if you aren't going to do that
it's okay because
what i really want you to remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
robin moore zubin ludwig to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters imudelki
theotha boyd becky sparks fernaby likes
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper adam rdl taylor shane ross
shaylee gourley brendan larose and tt
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards of my
patreon
[Music]
um
[Music]